I had tried committing suicide I took a
bottle of pills and obviously didn't
work because I'm sitting here today
thank God it just kind of goes to show
that it doesn't matter how pretty things
look on the outside and how great a life
is people still struggle as Savannah
Chrisley navigates life with both
parents Behind Bars she looks back at
another dark chapter this one from
childhood never really spoken about it
before I mean you don't think that dress
is too short this isn't the 1900s
the reality star grew up on the Family's
reality series Chrisley Knows Best
listen no one's life is laughter all the
time we wish it were but you know we
have a lot of real moments I mean it's
reality television on Tuesday Savannah
opens up on her unlocked podcast getting
honest about a traumatic moment that
wasn't captured by cameras I had tried
committing suicide never really spoken
about it before
um but I took a bottle of pills and
obviously didn't work because I'm
sitting here today years after the
incident Savannah worries there's
long-term effects that are catching up
to her ever since then it's I feel like
with my brain like my memory
it's the most frustrating thing in the
world because it feels so foggy there's
just things in your life that you need
to make a priority and when you notice
that you're not okay then you have
hopefully the tools to fix it and of
course there's what the 25 year old
can't fix what we will not do is we will
not break Savannah's parenting two
siblings while their parents taunted
Julie Chrisley survey combined 19-year
prison sentence following their
convictions last year for bank fraud and
tax evasion and I just want to say to
everyone we thank you for your continued
prayers and your support I've never seen
two people my parents be so steadfast in
their faith in the end the truth will
prevail may get harder before it gets
easier but we have faith
that's what we're going through this
storm that we're going through
it's bad it's tough It's hard it's
hurtful and it and would it be as hard
if the truth was out there no if Todd
and Julie could share a message with the
world what do you think they'd want them
to know you know I think they'd want
folks to know that they are the same
people they've always been that they
didn't do these things and they're going
to fight to get their name cleared I
just surrounded myself with my friends
and my family and not pushing people
away and accepting the help that people
were willing to give me I think that was
the biggest thing was so easy to push
people away
um but if you just allow people in and
to help you where they can you'll see a
world stiff
foreign